sociology and Women's Studies professor
Gail dines
presents her research on pornography
social cultural and economic impact in
America politics and prose bookstore in
Washington DC hosts this half-hour talk
these things are never built for
five-foot women you know so first of all
thank you everyone for coming it's a
pleasure to be here I'm really thrilled
that you came so I want to start with
where I was two years ago I was in this
huge hall and I was surrounded by
pornography hardcore pornography and you
could barely hear yourself think because
of the fake orgasm sounds coming from
the pornography and I'm standing there
thinking how did a nice Jewish girl from
Manchester England gets here and that's
the question that many people ask me how
did you end up doing what you do and if
somebody would have told me I was going
to be the expert on pornography right I
didn't think I was gonna go there so let
me tell you what happened I was living
in Israel at the time and I was working
at the rape crisis center I was 22 years
old and writing a dissertation for my
doctorate and somebody came up to me and
said to me this is anti porn feminist
slide show do you want to come and I
never really thought about pornography
before and I was 22 what did I know so I
said okay little did I know that night
it was gonna completely change my life I
couldn't believe the images I was seeing
I literally couldn't believe them and I
only could I not believe that men made
these images I couldn't believe that
other men found them arousing and it was
such a shock to me and I know I talked
about misogyny and woman hazing but
there's nothing like actually seeing
those images up there to deliver the
message to you so that night I went home
I called my adviser and I changed my
doctorate topic and I actually did the
doctorate on sociology of media with the
special case of pornography and from
that day on this has tethered me I'm not
going anywhere with this as long as the
porn industry I'm gonna be here so let
me tell you about what happened in
Israel an incredible thing happened to
me I've gone there believing in Zionism
and thinking this was a homeland for
Jews and then I got to have to basically
counsel Jewish women who've been raped
by Jewish men I also had to counsel
Jewish women who'd been battered by
Jewish men and Jewish girls who'd been
raped by Jewish thought by their fathers
and I began to think is this really a
homeland for Jewish women because the
same violence against women that goes on
in other places goes on here and then it
kind of all coalesced one day I'm
walking down the Main Street in Tel Aviv
and there's a big porn image flapping in
the wind and it's a woman on her knees
giving a man oral sex with Hebrew
everywhere and I thought the last time a
Jewish women Jewish woman was so shown
publicly on her knees like that was
probably in Nazi Germany where they made
pornographic images of Jewish women and
I went up to the guy and I said to him I
said there's a law against this and I'm
now going to go to the police and I'm
gonna get you arrested of course there
was no law right so they just said that
in the hope and he looks at me this man
now this is a man who's never done when
his studies hasn't got a PhD in media
and he looks at me he says to me I know
why you don't like that picture he said
that's you isn't it that's you up there
and I thought yes you are absolutely
right of course it's me as a woman of
course it's me because that's the
reality of pornography we're all up
there
vulnerable and into pornographic gays so
I went home and I started doing
sociology of media doctrine and I
approached pornography as one would
approach any form of media which is that
how do media images affect us how do
they impact on the world that we live in
and of course anyone who's progressive
politically talks about the role of the
media in an unequal Society now the fact
that if you have an access to most of
the resources and how do we leave the
jism eyes that how do we normalize that
through a medium and so when I began to
realize when I was reading media studies
but you know if people say images have
an effect if people say they construct
reality then surely pornography is gonna
do the same thing
surely pornography is going to construct
the reality of men because how can you
walk away from these images unchanged
and as I always say pornography delivers
PATRIOT a local ideology to men via the
penis which is an extremely successful
delivery system
so what I'm looking at here is how
images shape the reality and I'm gonna
take you through when I was at in Las
Vegas at the Adult Video News Awards and
they have a big Expo there and thousands
and thousands of fans porn fans descend
on that place and those thousands of
fans and me so I'm walking around there
and at first I stopped an interview some
of the porn producers and one man talks
to me and tells me how he's doing
something different he's not making
pornography his stuff is different and I
looked beside behind me and he's got a
picture basically an image of a woman
kneeling in a coffin as she's being
anally penetrated and I said the coffin
and he said well maybe the coffee is not
so good and so when we wait walked
around and round and I talked to these
people what I got was the same message
over and over again that they do not
know where this industry is going they
do not know how they got to do what they
do they are absolutely amazed that there
has been no law or very few lawsuits
against them and they can't believe
they're making this amount of money and
I was walking around there looking at
all of this pornography and you know
exhausted and demoralized and I sat down
next to an african-american woman who
was doing security the security guard
and I started to talk to her and she
wouldn't talk to me and she thought I
was a pornographer and she was having
nothing to do with the pornographers so
I had to tell her no I'm not a
pornographer I'm actually a feminist
anti-pornography I'm writing a book and
eventually she opened up to me and she
told me she said you know I have never
seen pornography before
nobody told me I was gonna have this as
my detail and I have got a cringy my
neck because I am looking down and
cannot stand to look at the pornography
and I looked around and indeed most of
these security guards were
african-american women and then she says
to me you know I've been divorced two
years and I can't find a good man and
now I understand why I never knew it
before and then just as she says that an
african-american woman walks by one of
the women from the pornography industry
and she's dressed in the usual garb
which means not very much and Patricia
the african-american woman I call it
Patricia she tapped me on the shoulder
and she says go and tell her it's not
good for a go and tell her this isn't
right and as she does that a fan comes
up to the african-american porn perform
and puts his hand on her crotch
she smiles everyone takes a picture and
Patricia just groans and there she was
plotting her exit as far away from Las
Vegas as possible so when I got home and
tried to make sense of this I began to
go through some of my notes and you know
some of it is actually quite humorous
although it's not really funny for
example I went up to a store where they
have what's called real dolls anyone
heard of real dolls these are these
anatomically correct dolls which worth
thousands of dollars I think there's a
six-month waiting list I know there's a
waiting list you can choose exactly what
size press what color pubic hair what
lipstick you get to choose all of that
and I went up to the guy who was behind
the desk there and I said you know I'm
interviewing people I'm a journalist I'm
writing a book and it's a wider Mumbai
these dolls he said well you know what
he said they really help men develop
relationships with women so this is what
he's telling me and then he says but you
know what he says a lot of women also
buy them for their husbands and I said
so why do you think that is he says oh
because these women want lesbian
experiences yes this is a lesbian
experience with the doll right and then
what he said to me she's so interesting
because this tells you something about
the industry I said to him did you
actually see Lars and the real girl is
anyone seen that movie and he said not
only did I see it he said we consulted
for it he said the day came out our
website crashed that's how popular it
was so you can see the meshing of the
industry with mainstream pop culture so
what I'm going to do is give you sort of
a brief introduction to my book and show
you what I actually wrote about and I
start by walking people through the porn
industry and I do that for a very
specific reason because many women
especially an older men they can't
understand why I'm so upset by just a
collection of pictures of women in a
cornfield smiling with no clothes on
well of course that's not what
pornography is today but that's the
image that a lot of people have so what
I have to say is I'm upset because
pornography today looks nothing like
that and that was bad enough in it's
sexism and objectification but we have
now taken it to a completely different
level so there's what I do is I explain
the acts in pornography
I'd go through the different sites and I
talk about the body punishing sex the
cruelty the violence the degradation the
debasement
I talk about some of the sex acts and
I'll give you an example of the
debasement one's called ATM as two
mouths where the band takes his penis
and puts it in a woman's anus and then
immediately into her mouth without
washing now what sexual arousal is there
outside of the debasement of the woman
because I hope can you think of what's
more sexually aroused than that
so what I look at is how pornography how
the sizzle in pornography how what makes
it hot is in fact that abasement of
women so I go through the difference
sites and I walk people through and the
question is you know what effect is is
gonna have on society because the first
age of downloading child pornography for
children is 11 years old so think about
this 11 year old boys the first entree
into sex is pornography and it's not
your father's Playboy it's that hard
core body punishing sex so the question
is is this gonna have on young boys
whose sexuality is still developing who
don't even own their sexuality yet and
before they own it they give it to the
pornographers and so think about we're
in a new world here because it used to
be that generations of boys would grow
up they would be you know have hormones
raging that go on find their fathers
playboy that have limited access to the
Playboy today it's anonymous it's
affordable and it's accessible 24 hours
a day and so what we're talking about is
bringing up a generation of boys on
images that we had never before brought
them up on now people say what's going
to be the effect of this well we don't
know because we're in the middle of a
social experiment and it's an experiment
I bet that most of you never signed on
to but we're gonna have to wait and see
but I can begin to tell you what some of
the effect is given the men I've
interviewed with Sharon is in the ball
the interviews I really talked to men
and asked them about their pornography
use and I do
open-ended so that they get to talk
louder than me directing them what they
should be talking about and a lot of
them now very interesting because I've
been doing this for over 20 years and I
used to get an incredible amount of an
anger and they wouldn't and
offensiveness and they would fight with
me and now I don't see that and what's
really strange is how they have actually
stopped being defensive and angry and
now they feel anxious about their
pornography use they feel the something
not right in it and I'll give you an
example I was in a huge
I gave election a huge hall in a
Northeastern University and the woman
stands up and says you know why a man
using pornography what's wrong with them
why do they do it and I said well rather
than ask me let's turn to the men in the
room and talk to them and one guy gets
up and he said you know I feel like I'm
gonna faint I'm so anxious but I have to
tell you my story and then he tells a
heartbreaking story of his habitual use
to pornography and then he sits down and
then other men start standing up telling
their stories and I get this now over
and over again of men who thought they
could go to pornography thought that
when it's done you know they zip up
their pants they zip up their head and
it's all over
no those images leaked into the real
world and what they tell me is first of
all but the more pornography they use
the more they expect best sex in their
real lives to look like the pornography
and they get a shock because it's not
like that because pornography is what I
call industrial-strength sex and most
women will not do that they will simply
not allow the men to do those acts to
them so these men get very upset they
get very angry they don't understand why
women they've seen thousands of women do
these things why well this one line next
to him do it also what they find is that
a lot of them lose interest in sex it
looks boring and banal and what they do
is they suffer their pornography to sex
with another human being and I've just
interviewed a woman whose husband is in
his twenties she's in her 20s not had
sex for months why he's addicted to
pornography and this is one of the
results that happen another thing that
happens is men find that they cannot
ejaculate without pulling up images of
their favorite porn star and they feel
bad about
because they want to be present during
sex they'd only be thinking of the
pornography or they have to pull up
their favorite scenes so this is having
a really big effect on the young men now
what about the women well a lot of the
women I interview talked about being
pressured into porn sex by their
boyfriends and by their hookups because
I don't know if most of you know what's
going on in college campuses today but
there's very little dating and there's
lots of hookup sex which are actually
hookup sex is porn sex is sex with no
into me it's intimacy is sex with no
connection it's sex with no I'm empathy
so what you have is really hookup sex
being porn sex which is being played out
on all the campuses studies show by the
way that the more hookup sex girls get
involved in and young women the more
that he press'd them lower their
self-esteem what studies show for boys
is the more hookup sex they do the
higher the self-esteem so you can see
who this is working for right not to
mention of course that women get much
fewer orgasms drawing up a hook up sex
surprise surprise okay so what happens
the young women tell me they feel
pressured to do these things and they
don't want to do them and yet they're
being told from cosmopolitan they're
being told from Sex in the City
everywhere they go they're getting the
message that pornography is okay lighten
up it's fun don't be a prude and so they
have got no alternative ideology with
which to come at these men and to say no
and to explain why they're not so
another thing that the women tell me
which is very interesting is how they
feel like from the word go living in a
hyper sexualized society they have felt
that they have to become sexual beings
very early on because as they wander
around the culture looking for images of
themselves of femininity and what it
means to be a woman the only image they
get is this hyper sexualized image and
we all know what it looks like you know
white young blond thin low-slung jeans
[ __ ] stamp in the back you know Pippa
and pierced navel all of these things
and this is what they get over and over
again now I think for those of us over
the age of 35 or even over the age of 30
when we were growing up trying to figure
out what it meant to be a woman we had
lots of choices not enough of course
because we needed the feminist movement
to expand our
he says but I remember thinking you know
what what fits and what fitted for me
what kind of identity as a woman made
sense for me and I had images to choose
from that we're not just the hyper
sexualized images today those images
have crowded out alternative images of
being female and what you have is women
saying they choose this but in reality
you can only choose something if you've
got an array of choices in front of you
and increasingly those choices are being
limited because in basically in our
society you can be visible or invisible
as a woman and what kid wants to be
invisible and you will be invisible if
you don't look like to sex like your
friend and this is why there's this kind
of push towards hyper sexualization so
this is also what I hear from the girls
and the young women so basically we have
now women being socialized into hyper
sexualization and we have boys being
trained through pornography what sex
looks like no wonder does that hookup
sex no wonder there's rape in hookup sex
as well which is what the studies are
showing that more women get raped in
hookup sex than any other relation
connection or relationship so these are
the key issues I talk about I also look
at racism in pornography which very few
people actually have ever looked at now
what's interesting is one in four films
released to the market is called
interracial and this is a black man and
a white woman and this is geared to
white men so the question becomes why do
white men want to watch black men
penetrate white women over and over
again and I was really thinking about
this because you know it's not that long
ago that black men got lynched for even
the threat of such a thing
so what's going on and then it dawned on
me if indeed pornography is about the
debasement of women what better way in a
racist society to debase a white woman
than have a penetrated over and over
again by a body that has been marked as
demonized has been seen as deviant ie
the black male body because the history
of racism in the society is the history
of the demonization of black sexuality
and so what you see in pornography is
the hyper sexual
and the eroticization of racism which
has a profound effect on communities of
color so I go into the image of
african-american women the image of
african-american men I go into the image
of Asian women and Asian men and I
really look at what it means to have
white skin in the pornographic industry
versus skin of color so those are some
of the issues that I talked about I'm
sure people have got some questions and
issues and things you'd like to bring up
so rather than we just go on I'm going
to open it up to some questions
so I'll start my way of introducing my
question by noting that in Shakespeare
there's a lot of sex and violence but I
don't mention that to endorse those
things but to mention that Shakespeare
is with us today the dreck he must have
been competing with probably had plenty
of it too but was Trek and forgotten and
so I asked about your reference to all
these video games how do you avoid being
accused of being a garden-variety moral
panic person who's talking about how
pinball and Elvis and the Beatles are
going to ruin our nation as well okay
good question okay because we always say
you know every generation has said oh
this is the end of the world you know
the younger generation just terrible but
let me tell you we have never done this
before we have moved from a print-based
culture to an image-based culture
whether the main form of communication
is the image now the image is
increasingly pornographic so the
question becomes what does that mean for
boys to grow up in that and I would say
it we are in serious serious trouble and
I don't think we've ever been in a
situation like that and also to talk
about immoral panics and one thing
people often - call me say are you
approved well let me say something if I
was speaking against fast-food industry
if I was talking about the obesity and
the health issues with fast food would
anyone accuse me of being anti eating so
why would I talk about pornography am i
accused of being anti sex it's the same
thing pornography is the
industrialization and commodification of
sex it's not sex just as fast food is
not just food it's the commodification
and industrialization of it so what I'm
talking about is an industry
specifically an industry so this is not
an issue about being a mall panic or
being a prude it's an issue about a huge
industry that he's having an enormous
impact on our culture
I was wondering if you've done any work
with Professor Catherine MacKinnon or if
you've you know worked with her well
heard of her she's very you know
well-known could you comment on that yes
quite a while ago actually we brought
the Dworkin MacKinnon legislation to
Boston and we tried basically it defines
pornography as a violation of women's
civil rights or anyone's civil rights
who's harmed in it so we brought that to
Boston I have to tell you I have a kind
of progressive understanding of
capitalism never though have I seen the
forces of capitalism Marshall itself
against a piece of legislation even the
guy who was running the hearings who had
been a longtime you know assistant and
aide to the rep said he had never seen
anything like the onslaught against this
but he said not even the insurance
industry is this bad so I mean that's
the kind of stuff that's what happened
on him we worked with yeah Catherine
MacKinnon and the late Andrea Dworkin
thank you I was reading Common Sense a
second ago and I was thinking what would
Paine think about this like essentially
like from a girl from Manchester I mean
I would like to know your perspective is
long how you think at least well there
used to be a bridge between the between
America and Europe and now that bridge
seems to be ever closer the discrepancy
seems to be closer together and I was
thinking to myself do you see with the
proliferation of the internet mass
communication all these things do you
see the bridge coming closer together
and what do you think though you mean if
the country's coming to
at least our thoughts on sexuality
towards you yeah I think that's a great
question because what pornography does
is it Universal Isis the way we think
about sex because the Internet is
everywhere now and pornography is one of
the most downloaded as you know it's one
of the most sought-after images on the
Internet so I would say that even
cultural differences cultural divides
are now breaking down
thanks to this sort of generic
plasticized formulaic image of sex which
is what pornography is so I think the
divisions are gonna you're gonna see a
lot less yes thank you
question yeah actually I have a few but
I'll just ask two the first is more
about how you were able to talk to
people in the industry themselves and
have them open up about this because to
me I'm thinking they would want to guard
their thoughts if you're an outsider
who's already whom they may already
sense it's sort of again is against
their industry how did you get them to
open up you know what's really
interesting is when I was there at the
expo it's three days long and you know
what they were bored that they were just
simply bored and I would go and talked
and this I couldn't sit down they'd be
thrilled to talk about it
it was amazing I went through notebook
after notebook taking notes and just to
say what I didn't say is you know
interesting I got an email last week
from one of the porn producers I
interviewed and he said he'd read my
book I'm one of the porn producers and I
want you to know you're extremely
exactly right
he said I've left poor porn industry
everything you say about pornography is
true and at the moment we're having
conversations because he's telling me
what really went on behind the season
this was a man who made pornography for
15 years so yeah that's that and so they
did open up my second question is more
about how do you talk to someone to the
men out there you know we are brothers
you know friends guy friends that watch
porn see porn how do you talk to them in
a way that's not abrasive because I'm
sure they're going to be sensitive
anyway if the whole point is that it
demoralizes women how do you talk to
them so that they get your world and get
where you're coming from and their way
of being well you know I say to my
students look you're not gonna if you're
looking to date a guy the chances of you
finding a guy who's not used pornography
is very very low but everyone's entitled
to one mistake that's fine okay but now
you're dating him and now you're talking
about pornography and why you don't want
him to use it then he has to stop but I
say to women is you cannot be in a
relationship with the man who is using
pornography and it be an equal 1 because
pornography is about the inequality
between women and men now how do you do
it you have to talk to them you there's
lots of stuff for there's a group that I
belong to called stop porn culture and
if you go to stop porn culture calm
there's lots of resources
there lots of articles and you need to
basically introduce the men in your life
to a critical analysis of pornography
because many men have never thought
critically about it because when they
look at pornography they're aroused and
you try and have a rational discussion
with an erect penis it doesn't work okay
so they need not to be aroused and to
talk about it so have a look at for the
resources on stop porn culture yes hello
there was a very nice presentation by
listening to you a scene came to my mind
of an old movie Last Tango in Paris and
this is when Marlon Brando has many many
names to name the new male organ and
most of those names are vulgar so my
question is I'd like to know whether you
think that pornography is a dominance a
collateral damage spinoff of Western
civilization and Christianity with the
idea that you know the scene the sex is
something that is very I think it's
similar to the question that the
gentleman asked but with the spin
towards the the cultural influence of
Western as I said Christianity in our
world I mean you know we got a porn
industry you can't as a social scientist
I can't find one reason there's multiple
ways I think one of our views about sex
as being sort of dirty has bleeds into
pornography because if you look at
pornography you know sex is considered
dirty in pornography she is considered
dirty the names they always call have
got the word you dirty [ __ ] you dirty
this you dirty that but I think what I
tried to say is look you know we've
probably always had pornography around
us but what's critical when we look at
pornography is we have to look at it as
an industry and it began in 1953 with
the first edition of Playboy so what I'm
interested in is less so in looking at
sort of the vast you know issues out
there and really honing in on how the
industry develop from 1953 to present
day to understand how it functions and
it functions as all other industries
drew do so if you ask me why there's so
much pornography around today I would
say because it has become a massive
industry because it is profit driven
because it exists within a capitalist
market and the goal of the pornographers
of course is to make money
that's why you've got such a big
industry and the fact that it's
delivered through the internet is
crucial because now it's so accessible
that changed the face of the industry
quick question what how many billion
dollar-a-year babies they say it's very
hard to estimate but one of the figures
that's branding around a lot is 97
billion dollars a year 13 billion in
America 97 billion around the world
thank you very much I'm interested in
some of the questions that you posed I
got here a little late so maybe you're
already approached them so forgive me
but one of the things you said was what
do men get out of a TM now I'm wondering
did you interview men who said yes I
practice that and find out what they do
get out of it one question go ahead okay
let me tell you that I haven't
specifically interviewed men on that
what I did do is I went to the porn
discussion boards which is where the
aficionados of porn hang out basically
and I read what they were saying about
ATM and there is a thread called messy
ATM and in this thread hundreds of
hundreds of postings talking about how
great it is to watch the woman literally
have to eat feces without knowing it and
how thrilling that was and they even
tell you at what point in the movie to
go to so you can see her doing it and
that she didn't know it and they said
one guy said this was a moment of Zen in
pornography I've never reached before so
this is what they like the debasement if
for this if what they write is basically
true those films they actually try to
show you that it's a TM but it isn't
it's a and then clean up and then but
I've heard that they don't clean up in
the films Thank You Craig the effort
they create the impression that they're
not yeah but the other question is when
you interview these people seems to me
that you have to have a lot of controls
to get anywhere close to the truth the
context in which you you ask it the how
do you filter out whether people are
just trying to appear
to get the right answers as opposed to
the the real feelings that they have
about something I mean it just seems to
me that any of psychological and
sociological studies need a great deal
of control to get anywhere close to the
truth no and of course and obviously the
more you interview and the more you
begin to see patterns I mean the
sociologists there's a sociologist where
I look for patterns and I began to look
at patterns of what they were saying I
want to says what a lot of the research
in here is actually from the porn
industry itself because I read Adult
Video News which is the portrayed paper
of the porn industry also experts which
is their business and website so I mean
it's not just through interviews it's
also through what that's talking about
in their actual press and I think what
happens when you interview them I have
to say both of them were really opened
up about the industry and what's good
about when this guy contacted me the
producer and said you know you were
right and we've had long conversations
so for over an hour or so and then we
gonna have more he's basically saying
the same things I've heard over and over
again I've not heard anything different
so that's how I do
thank you I'm sorry thank you do you
think it's possible to be a consumer of
pornography and also have you know a
quote-unquote healthy sexuality whatever
that might mean and I'm wondering to
what extent the pernicious effects of
pornography are depends on the more
extreme types that you've discussed
because I've heard that you know there's
supposedly a subset of the pornography
industry that's supposed to be more
friendly or appealing to women so yeah
it's the most profitable on the internet
it's called gonzo by the industry and if
the industry business website is to be
believed and if the adult video news is
to be believed then that's the most
profitable because that's the one men
use alone what they'll use with women
more is what's called the features which
is kind of a story and it tries to mimic
the Hollywood movie but he's still body
punishing sex I would say that if you're
consuming pornography what you are
getting aroused to is the debasement and
dehumanization of women and I do not see
how that can translate in any way into
what I would say as a healthy
relationship which is one which is built
on equality and respect so I can't see
how that would work
thank you
yes I just had a question what sort of
your long-term strategy in the you know
that on a war on porn if you want to
call it that but like are you trying to
criminalize it or just sort of weed out
the most offensive practices
okay well it's multi-pronged one of the
things we did with stopped porn culture
is three of us wrote a anti-porn slide
show which we give free of charge you
can download it from Stockholm culture
comes with a hundred images and 50
minutes script we give that out because
we want people to start creating
awareness and consciousness and doing an
educational program about the harms of
pornography so one of the things we
really want to do is raise public
consciousness as to the harms of
pornography what I would also like to
see at some point is to empower women
and anyway indeed men as well who have
been hurt through the pornography
industry at the point of either
production or consumption which means
I'd like to see it in the Criminal Code
in the Civil Code sorry not the Criminal
Code I don't think the Criminal Code is
the way to go for the pornographers and
it's not work because look obscenity
charges it's not worked and I think that
women should be empowered especially to
be the ones to go after the
pornographers because what we could say
to them is look hey you remember that
woman you bought for 50 dollars well
it's gonna cost you a lot more than
fifty dollars basically we're saying
women's lives matter and that we're
gonna put a price on them thank you
after working now for the feminist cost
for many many years I'm still shocked
that about 90% of the TV commercials
when they show cleaning products is
always a woman's hand cleaning and so
there's a sense that it's natural for
women to clean and it's embarrassing for
men to clean again debasing women as the
cleaners again you know how do we
mobilize both women and men to teach
kids that hey it's okay for everyone to
do these sorts of things and it's not
woman's natural job to clean or to be
sexual in this you know terrible way
punishing way and get to the media you
know stop the commodification of the
industry tell man that is wrong well the
only way I can see in all of these
issues is we have to build a robust
feminist movement we cannot do this
outside of feminism and what I want to
say very clearly pornography
didn't invent this ideology pornography
is part of our culture what comes out of
in was in pornography is in the culture
that sort of woman-hating anti female
position is not just something that
pornography does and when you see in
advertisements when you see it in images
everywhere you're just seeing a lesser
version of it so that's what I'd say and
I think what we need to do is my less
common because we need to and is to say
you know this is a call if this is a
call for anything is to join the
feminist movement and to help us build
an organization that resists the porn
culture in general thank you very much
Gail dines is a sociology and Women's
Studies professor at Wheelock College
she's also the editor of gender race and
class in media and contributor to
pornography the production and
consumption of inequality for more
information visit Gail dines com join
our conversation on the American
Revolution